les grecs box est disponible dans le
commerce depuis mardi un coffret qui
regroupe 78 offres culturelles de
loisirs ou d'hébergement à prix bradés
-50% nuits d'hôtel visites de musées ou
encore paintball il s'agissait de de
partir d'une réflexion très simple qui
était de dire aujourd'hui les gens
partent moins loin moins longtemps en
vacances proposons leur de redécouvrir
ou de découvrir tout simplement les
yvelines l'entreprise martèle qu est
habitué aux boks en tous genres mail y
box et son premier partenariat avec une
collectivité l'initiative vient en effet
du conseil général qui espère booster le
secteur du tourisme on a fait le calcul
à peu près si les acheteurs les futurs
acheteurs de cet eee box
utilisent tout ce qui leur est offert
ils font une économie de 3000 euros donc
vous voyez pour un investissement de
moins de 30 euros c'est une un bon
placement mais au delà de ça c'est bien
entendu destinée à mieux faire connaître
les yvelines dans le département le
tourisme reste en effet peu développée à
l'exception du site du château de
versailles ce projet de boxe est dans
les cartons depuis un an et demi il a
fallu dans un premier temps convaincre
les partenaires les hôtels qui assurent
principalement une clientèle d'affaires
en semaine y ont vu un moyen de combler
leur faible taux d'occupation du
week-end en moyenne moins de 50% donc
c'est une façon de bloquer dans les
yvelines
nos clients potentiels et essayer de
siphonner un peu paris qui qui attire
vraiment trop par rapport à nous leurs
offres ne sont disponibles que le
week-end toutes les activités du coffret
peuvent être utilisés une fois dans la
limite d'un an